Who am I there are people believe that
this world is fairing it
they saw the lollipops and rainbows
we don't do lollipops and rainbows we
know those are pretty colors such as
hide what the world really is black and
white soon they'll shout save us
we convince ourselves that they were
gone but they were just hibernating the
game for everybody all please
coordinated simultaneous attacks at the
homes of Tulsa PD so the cops hide their
faces and now the bad guys don't know
where they live and who doesn't want a
secret identity
[Applause]
people who wear masks are dangerous we
should be scared of them because they're
hiding something
Laurie Blake FBI you know how you can
tell the difference between a masked cop
and a vigilante no me neither
near the vast and insidious conspiracy
I play towards youth our own Lakes poem
[Music]
are you maybe yeah dr. Menon
he lives on [ __ ] Mars you curse too
much John I just forgot
[Music]
happy Comicon week everyone
dr. Manhattan has returned to earth so
we got a brand new watchman HBO trailer
and a release date for the series so
we'll break all the Easter eggs down and
explain what's going on with the story
because it's comic-con week we're doing
that new giveaway for the IMAX tickets
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Watchmen moment on the video I'll name a
new winner at the end of this as you
probably knew before this based on the
last trailer they released Jeremy Irons
is playing an older version of
Ozymandias it seems like the world
believes he's dead at the beginning of
this series because they place a couple
very obvious newspaper headlines
throughout the trailer giving you very
special information and the first one is
Adrian feat believed to be dead but
later in the trailer he sets off this
explosion he's very clearly hiding out
in one of his mansions and it seems like
he sets things in motion using a very
similar type of tragedy that he did at
the end of the original series so just
to be clear this is 30 years after the
original series so that's why a lot of
the characters from the original story
are older characters on the show being
played by some very famous actors I'll
explain who they are but Jeremy Irons is
just one of them playing the older
version of Ozymandias we finally see dr.
Manhattan show back up on earth at the
end of the trailer amidst this
celebration if you couldn't tell the
blue hands because the lighting the
trailers kind of dark he picks up the
blue mask then looks at it but they
don't reveal his face so I don't know
who the actor is that they cast to play
that character because before this had
happened it was only a theory that he
was show up like I was guessing that
they would use that as their sort of
Game of Thrones white Walker reveal with
the night king like they would save it
for a future season or the season finale
but if they're putting into the trailer
here he might actually show up before
the end of the first season but I would
be very surprised if this is something
that happens in the first episode it's
probably something that they build up to
after they do a little bit of
world-building to let you know what the
world is like in present day we see the
owl ship so now I'm wondering because
Don Johnson is piloting it they're
trying to take down this other airplane
if he's playing an older version of
niteowl - but they opened a trailer with
a vigilante that looks like a newer
version of hooded justice crashing
through this store window to stop a
robbery
you see cans of beans on the shelf then
you see the Looking Glass character
somewhere else watching it all unfold on
TV eating
beans out of a can which is a reference
to Rorschach eating beans out of a can
during the original series then they lay
in this vast conspiracy storyline where
you have the cult of Rorschach which
clearly knows the truth about what
happened from the original series I
think the idea is is that they're the
ones that read Rorschach's Journal and
believed what he said so maybe when they
was published after the events of the
original series everybody read it but
only some people believed what he was
saying at it and some people believed
the lie that Ozymandias was trying to
perpetrate you see the Angela Abram
character played by Regina King she's
one of the main characters of the series
she's both a vigilante and a detective
on the police force the whole idea in
the present day of the series is that
vigilantes since the events of the first
series have been outlawed the only way
that you can continue to be a vigilante
is as if you're member of a law
enforcement agency so that means the
police that means the FBI we learned
that genes smart is playing the older
version of Silk Spectre - from the
original series but she's a member of
the FBI now and she's using her father's
name so it seems like after the events
of the original series she never wound
up getting married tonight
owl but obviously like I said it's
implied that he's being played by Don
Johnson in the present series so they do
have scenes together so even if they're
not together romantically in present day
of the series they still have all that
history together so a lot of the scenes
from the original trailer where he's
talking about the end of the world make
a little more sense where they're
talking playfully to each other there's
a reference to the original Minute Men
with the comedian in hooded justice you
see the line comedy beats tragedy that's
actually a reference to tragedy plus
time equals comedy more honoring the
legacy of the comedian cynical sense of
humor like the whole conspiracy
storyline that characters talked about
during the trailer it seems like things
have gotten better for the world but
also worse at the same time because as
genes smartsilk Specter character says
because you can't tell the difference
between a vigilante in a cop wearing a
mask like they're trying to make the
cult of Rorschach seem like this group
of radicals because you see them
standing with this older version of the
American flag when they're burying the
cop earlier in the trailer you see a
very different version of the American
flag in present-day with way more than
52 stars but when you see this cult of
Rorschach in the trailer park here
assembling you see the statue of Nixon
from the original series with an old
class
version of the American flag so it's
just a reminder that this is an
alternate history and so much time has
gone by a lot of stuff has changed some
things for the worse as this conspiracy
storyline is implying one of my favorite
Easter eggs for this though is when
they're sort of going back and forth
between the different personas of Regina
Kings character her vigilante detective
persona when she's taking down these
criminals in this cult of Rorschach but
also when she's in the classroom with
these little kids making the smiley face
symbol with cracked eggs in the bowl if
you look over on the side of this scene
here it says important US presidents in
Robert Redford's picture is on there
there's a newspaper later in the series
saying that he's not seeking re-election
so it's hard to say how long he's been
president but they're trying to say that
whatever it is that he did while he was
president and whatever Nixon did while
he was president during the original
series is as important for US history as
what Lincoln and George Washington did
that's like saying they're the greatest
US presidents in history so whatever it
is that Robert Redford did during his
term it sounds like it's gonna be huge
you may have also noticed that Black
Manta from the Aquaman movie is playing
Regina King's husband on the series the
tick-tock chant of the cult of Rorschach
obviously a reference to the Doomsday
Clock from the original series and now
in present day they're counting down to
another tragedy but also in a larger
context they're counting down to the
return of dr. Manhattan I love the way
that they go to that live stream it's
24/7 live stream dr. Manhattan returns
to Mars because he was on Mars he said
that he was going away at the end of the
original series to create life in
experiment with his powers in some
alternate dimension dr. Manhattan is one
of the most powerful comic-book
characters in history
he's vastly vastly more powerful than
characters like Superman he can
rearrange matter on the molecular level
with that thought he can instantly
teleport himself across the universe
with the thought and he can see into the
future so he's virtually on nishan more
of a literal God instead of being a
metaphorical God in the sense of a
Superman character so if he's coming
back onto this series and if there's
this long-running conspiracy going on
I'm curious to see how it tries to rope
him into things because the whole idea
of the original series is is that he was
being misled by Ozymandias right up into
the end when he realized what was going
on
agreed to go along with it because he
recognized it as necessary for the human
race to progress but clearly based on
Ozymandias his actions in the trailer
his actions in the original series did
not have their intended effect you see
him on horseback riding past the flag
from tales of the black freighter
there's all these scenes with Regina
King talking to this little girl here so
it's hard to tell what her role is in
the series but it seems like she gets
tied up in this larger conspiracy that
she starts to uncover it's hard to tell
who Lou Gossett jr. is playing on the
series but he might be playing an older
version of a character from the original
series he jokes that he might be dr.
Manhattan but clearly he's not meant to
be dr. Manhattan because he shows up at
the end of the trailer the other
detective character in the red tracksuit
is called Red Scare he's based on Russia
and Soviet tropes he's just another
member of the police force remember if
you want to be a sanctioned vigilante
you have to be a member of the police or
the FBI in the case of Silk Spectre if
you notice the scene of the courtroom
here if you look at the picture in the
background it's a picture of the monster
from the end of the original comic
series so it seems like they're being
true to that so within the fictional
world of this Watchmen series that's
actually what happened at the end
instead of what happened at the end of
the movie so just to be clear this is a
sequel to the comic book series not a
sequel to the movie so if you're big
alan moore a comic book Watchmen fan
you'll probably enjoy a lot of this and
you'll probably notice a bunch of the
easter eggs they're saying that the
series is premiering in october so i'm
assuming that's the beginning of october
because they'd have to finish all 10
episodes by the beginning of december so
i would plan on october 6 being the
premiere date of course i'll be doing
weekly episode videos for it in easter
eggs if there are any big easter eggs
you spotted in the trailer that i did
not mention in the video just post them
in the comments below
but there'll be a big Marvel phase 4
Comic Con panel tonight so of course my
next video will be for whatever they
drop during that as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
the video when I post it so no worries
congratulations to eduardo Cortese
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details click here for The Witcher
Netflix trailer with Henry Cavill
Superman himself talked about DC
Universe and click here for that brand
new Rick and Morty season 4 Comic Con
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight
you